おっ
今現在東京の学習塾で今日主張しておりますこそで言うと申します
今自分の会社の中で広げているものがこの夢応援便がでもの広げています
あまり難しい考えなくていいと思いますただ単に子供たちと夢の話をたくさん使用
そんな簡単な話です夢を得メンダー
聞くのは3つだけです
3つだけの質問で夢が引き出せます
まず1つ目
夢ありますかできています
そうすると
まあ夢
ありますよ僕っていうこ
何かいますてくれると思います
例えば
サッカーが大好きな中学校2年生の男の子
この子の夢サッカー選手なんじゃなくてバイエルンミュンヘンカー
レアルマドリードに入団したいっていう有名です
でその夢を聞いた時に僕がしたことは
じゃあ
同夜第六課5入館するって話をしました
そのことを話した時には例えば今中学校2年生なので高校サッカーをするのか
大学サッカーするのか jリーグまで行ってから
バイエルにいくのかそれとも中学校卒業したら
バイエル言っちゃえばいいんじゃないかっていう話もしました
彼のサッカー実際にしてるとこ見たことないんでわからないんですが
では僕自身は本気で by n 入団できると思っています
こんな風に夢がある子いますが
夢
内容っていう思います
その後に次にする質問二つ目です
昔はありましたかという質問しますそれに続けて僕自身の話なんですが先生はねえっと
一番最初の夢は忍者になることだったんだよ
いうとまあ
何そりゃみたいなアートだったらあったかもしれない話をしてくれます
一人いるんですが中学校3年生の男の子です
昔はね建築士になろうと思ったんだけど辞めちゃったんだよねー
辞めた理由は建築士の試験が難しいって聞いたから
その男の子なぜ検知になろうと思ったのっていうとちょっと力仕事はまた p じゃ
ないけど
地図に残る仕事がしたいんだ
だったら建築士になればいい
どうやったらなれるんだろうねって一緒に話しました近道ってあるのかなって話もし
ました
でそれで2人で探していたところ日本大学に入ると
事件が通りやすい
っていう話を
ただしました
なのでこの子と一緒にじゃあ日本大学に入れる高校を探してその高校に入ればいいって
いう話につながっていきました
昔はありましたかの質問にもじゃなかったですねえって有効
いるんです
その子に対する3つ目の質問
それが今ハマっているコトとか楽しいことってありますか
やって楽しいことってありますかという質問をします
そうするとちょっとずつ出てくる子いるんですハマっていることぐらいはあると思うの
でいると思います
すごく引っ込み思案
もう本当に人と話すのがと不得意が人見知りの小学校6年生の女の子がいました
出会った時にはもう本当にはい分かったさようなら
裏四回はない子本当にづらくていやどうしたらいいかなって思っていたんですがまぁ
その他にも今の3つの質問
繰り返し繰り返し聴いていきました
小学校6年生の夏休みの前に面談をしたときに今やって楽しいことってあるとか
小学校最後6年生の夏だしやりたいことありますかってお相撲した時に友達と二公開に
期待
小沢って言ってきました
それでお母さんに頼んで服を買いに行かせてもらったっていうのがあります
てその年の冬
また次の面談があったときに
じゃファッションの関係とかってどうっていう話をしていって
例えばファッション関係するショートって言ってもたとえモデルになるとか
あとは
雑誌の編集者とかあとは
服を振る人アパレル関係とか全部ファッションに関連する勝負だけどどんなのが興味
ありそうっていうとちょっとモデルに興味ありそう
っていう
じゃあも出るんだろうって言って
でもモデルになるからちょっとよくわかんなかったので自分で調べてみてよって言って
調べてもらいました
でその次面談した時に
先生私芸能事務所に入ってるんですってっ
言われたんです
びっくりしてへんってなって
すごく通りある立ったんですが今で卍ほども忘れないくらいすごかったですね
でこの間面談した時に最後にお母様が入ってくれたのが高校生になったらちょっと付の
活動を本格的にやっていこうかなって話をしてくれて今中学校一年生なんですが落ちて
夢の話してくれてます
で話をするときに使うアンケート最初に書いてもらったものが
ぐらんだったんですが今解除が男系たには将来について女優かモデルになりたい
って理由も読者まではいろんなかわいい服を着て得てたくさん書いてくれてます
自分の言葉で自分の文字で書いていている
これが去年の夏休み前に書いてもらったもの
ここに書いてある友達と遊ぶこととか服っていうのは僕が面談をしながら書き足した
ものなので提出してもらった時にはクーラーんでした
これが
こうなるんです
夢がヴィッツ彼だけどここまで自分が文字にできるんだな
夢の力すごく感じました
ここまで夢の話たくさんしてきているんですが
こんな経験がきっかけになっていると思います
3年前の2月に自分の親友が自殺しました
高校生からの中だったのでも何でも仲良くて一緒に上京して
ずっと鶴瓶と中でした
最後に会ったのか
2つの1週間前
まったく全長はなく気づくことができなかった
今考えてみても
なんでだろうな思いますが
たくさん今までいろんなこと話してきたのに将来の話あんましたことなかったらって
考えています
彼にとって大人になるイメージだったりだとか
この先の将来っていうのか明確に見えてなかった
そんな風に考えるなりました
頭なかったは12セラー
見えなかった将来
それを子供たちと一緒に探していく
その思いから自分の夢応援面談というものが始まっていきました
この将来でにありますかという質問
ずっとずっと自分は繰り返しています
子どもたちの将来の夢考える夢応援面談
始めるときにじゃあまず子どもたちからみようということで夢ありますかという質問を
していったんですがその途中で気づくことがありました
そこは保護者との関係があまりよくないところもある
親の接し方が少し良くないところがあるんじゃないか
っていうものです
面談のスタートに症例になりますかで聞くと
あまり考えてないよねって
保護者のかたが口を挟むんです
これが多いんです
それにつられて子どもたちは
ない
言ってしまう
これじゃあこの先考えられないんだろう
これじゃあ夢のことを考えられないしどうやって過ごしていくのかわかんなくなって
しまう
見失ってしまうんじゃないかなって思います
2の道普通の道って言ってもわからないですが大学に進学して就職をしていく
その子とした考えられなくなってしまうんじゃないかなと思っています
僕の考えるのは大人の子どもへの接し方
ここに問題があると思っています
高校進学もそうですし大学進学
また大手企業への就職
そういうのは絶対じゃないと思っています塾行っている先生が高校進学が絶対じゃない
とがおかしいんですが
絶対じゃないと思っています
自分のなりたい夢見つかってそこに向けての道であればどんな道でもいい
そういうふうに本気で思っています
自分が子どもと接するときには
ずっと考えていることそれは
まず子どもの心の中には絶対になり彼がある
絶対に将来の夢絶対にあると思って考えています
それに加えて
その先どんなに漠然とした夢であっても
ヤムチャだろうって夢であっても
認めるというところです
絶対にしてはしない
ここで否定をしてしまうとそこで次の夢がございてしまいます
将来でね
幸せになりたいって言ってくれています
さっきと愕然として夢ですね
この子に将来ね何言って言って幸せになりたいって言われたので
しあわせって何だろうねって言うと
例えば大金持ちになるとか
あとは
大家族を持つとか
あとは美味しいもの食べたいとかえっ
そんなでも夢なんです
職業なんかじゃなくていい夢なんて何でもいいと思います
これこそがこの子の生きる意味
であればいいから
そういうふうにぼかぁさんがいれます
この先この子たちが前を向いて生きる
そのために将来に目が少しでも役立てばいい
そう考えています
僕がこんなふうに毎日毎日子どもたちと将来目何将来に皆に考えて何時次どうするのっ
て話をしているので今度は子供達の方が
先生次はね昆明持ってるんだよね剥がしてくれたんです
ほとんどんどんどん前に出てきます
やっぱり中学校とか高校生なので自分の将来の夢って語るの難しいかなっていう年代の
子たちなんですが言葉にしてくれます
さらに北に言葉にかけてくれるので他の友達も聞いている
お前それになるのとか
本当に友達に聞かれてもいいようなそんな感覚でみんな話してくれるん
みんな口に出してそれをさっき言った認める
それを常夏通してやっています
これこそが前を向いて生きていく理由あるんじゃないのかなと
思っています
さっきの
この3つの質問夢はありますか
質問昔はあった今ハマっているもなんですか
このたった3つの質問だけでこのもの中から何かが出てきます
それを絶対に潰してほしくない
そこから対応をスタートしてほしい
認めること
それだけやってもらえれば十分ですそれが僕の今日お話ししたかった夢を応援麺山の
全貌ですありがとうございました